singer-songwriter how [__] great is
it that you can sing your own songs I
mean that's something you're born with
right you could always sing uh no no
like honestly man really like yeah I
have you got YouTube can I I can pull up
a song that I wrote when I was 14. we
can get it so if you type in Ed Sheeran
addicted and this is a song that I made
when I was 14 and you can hear I want to
hear that I didn't have talent I really
didn't and I had and this is me that
this is me at 14 singing this and I got
successful at 19. oh here we go
[Music]
I think I took too much
I'm addicted to you
I'm not kidding let me hear a little
more
[Music]
this is great I love that you so you're
telling me you perfected this cause I
hear you sing and I go well he just can
sing
did you take less I mean because this is
not just
when did you how did when did you
realize well no I can see
all right you can kill the Ed's gonna
this is what I play to kids and I'm like
look this is me at 14. I wrote The A
Team at 18 so four years later I made
the a team and I recorded it and in four
years I learned Harmony I learned how to
sing in tune I learned how to perform I
learned how to do in time and you can do
it what was it from going out and
Performing that you learned that or did
you know time and time left again yeah
like I I'm sure I'm sure you'll agree
with me with this you learn nothing from
success nothing you learn everything
from the failures and this is the thing
that annoys me about the state that the
world is in at the moment is no one
talks about failure anymore it's like
shame like failure is shame and it's
like oh let's just bury that and not
talk about no one goes oh what did we
learn from this whereas with success
everyone shouts about it but there's
nothing in success success happens from
failing hundreds of times this is such
such a great message and people don't
believe it I truly believe especially
with that demonstration you just gave us
if you were 14. I truly believe
that if you work hard enough at
something I don't care what it is that
you can really become an expert you can
become great but it doesn't just happen
overnight you have to be rubbish and you
have to have people laugh at you and you
have to have people go oh go get a real
job no yeah this isn't really going to
work you have to and you just have to
have belief that eventually it is gonna
get better where the hell does that
belief in yourself come from the belief
comes from and I'm sure you feel the
same way as well of like what else are
you gonna do I love playing music I love
writing songs I love performing and I'm
like I can't do anything else this is
this is all I love to do and I early on
when I was like 17 18 I remember I
played a wedding
and I played covers for two hours and at
the end of the wedding I got given 200
pounds which was like the month's rent I
was like oh my God I can get paid
singing songs and that in that
realization I was like whatever happens
I know I'm good somewhere in music I'll
be able to make a living this is the
thing that I say to kids as well when
they when I when they want to get into
music I'm like don't have a plan B
Because if you have a plan B when it
gets difficult you'll quit and you'll do
the plan B if you only have plan a you
will succeed because you'll just be like
I have to do it so it's gonna happen
foreign